bienvenidos a esta crónica de ciencia y
tecnología en france24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y en esta ocasión los
acompaño desde casa por la pandemia de
kobe 19 durante las últimas semanas el
turismo espacial ha ganado atención tras
los viajes realizados por richard
branson fundador de virgin y jeff bezos
fundador de amazon ambas fueron salidas
cortas de la tierra lo que se conoce
como vuelos suborbitales en los que se
abandona la atmósfera terrestre pero no
se da una vuelta al planeta estas
aventuras de multimillonarios han
despertado la curiosidad de miles de
personas puede que no sean hechos
históricos para la astronáutica pero si
suponen hitos para el turismo espacial
branson fue el primero hombre en salir
de la tierra en una nave o avión propio
el pasado 11 de julio con su vehículo
fabricado por la rama espacial de su
compañía virgin galactic llegó a los 85
kilómetros de altura
la marca que establece eeuu para decir
que se abandonó la tierra nueve días
después del turno fue para besos en su
nave new se parte en honor al primer
astronauta estadounidense alan shepard
la nave desarrollada por la rama
espacial de su compañía blue origin se
llegó a los 106 kilómetros de altura la
marca internacional en un viaje que
rompe varios récords una de las
participantes es la piloto willi funk
que hizo parte del mercury karting un
programa secreto de la nasa en el que la
década de los 60 fueron seleccionadas 13
mujeres aviadoras para que se sometieran
a las mismas pruebas físicas y
psicológicas que habían superado siete
hombres del programa mercury se ven las
participantes no sólo aprobaron sino que
en algunos casos como el de walk y
superaron las marcas registradas por los
hombres pero los resultados no fueron
suficientes para la nasa que decidió
poner fin al programa ellos sí se
convirtieron en astronautas y ellas no
años después se les reconoció como
pioneras de la aviación pues a sus 82
años funk salió de la tierra y ahora es
la persona de más edad en llegar al
espacio agua
quiero darte las gracias cariño por qué
lo hiciste posible para mí he estado
esperando mucho tiempo para finalmente
lograrlo he hecho muchos entrenamientos
de astro
en todo el mundo rusia eeuu y siempre
pude vencer a los hombres en lo que
estaban haciendo porque siempre fui más
fuerte y siempre lo he hecho todo por mi
cuenta
pero no salía al espacio hice cosas al
aire libre volé aviones unas 19.000
horas me encantó y me encantó estar aquí
con todos ustedes con tu familia los
cuatro lo pasé genial
y quiero ir de nuevo rápido
a su vez oliver day men de 18 años hijo
de un millonario neerlandés es ahora el
más joven en estar en el espacio jeff y
marc esos son los primeros hermanos en
coincidir fuera de nuestro planeta y
este vuelo de la nave new separar es el
primero no pilotado o pilotado por un
ordenador y el primero con una
tripulación completamente civil
le dije a esta tripulación chicos si
tienen ganas déjenme invitarlos cuando
estemos allá arriba y saben hay todos
los tipos de adrenalina de emoción de
novedad pero tomémonos un minuto unos
segundos para mirar con calma afuera y
pensar que esto no solo es una aventura
es decir es una aventura y es divertido
pero también es importante porque
estamos dando el primer paso de algo
grande vamos a construir un camino al
espacio para que nuestros hijos y sus
hijos puedan construir un futuro
necesitamos hacerlo para resolver los
problemas que tenemos aquí en la tierra
commissioners cambiamos de tema y vamos
ahora países bajos donde fue inaugurado
el primer puente en acero impreso en 3-d
del mundo está en ámsterdam sobre uno de
los canales del famoso barrio rojo el
puente mide 12 metros de largo y pesa
cerca de 4.500 kilos su construcción
requirió el uso de varios robots que
calentaron el acero a 1500 grados
celsius para imprimir el puente cab acá
la tecnología que usamos para imprimir
el puente es en realidad una tecnología
que desarrollamos nosotros mismos es una
combinación de equipo de soldadura y
robots pero lo que realmente
desarrollamos es el software que está
impulsando todo el sistema y lo está
convirtiendo en una impresión 3d
entonces toda la tecnología en cierto
modo es completamente nueva
el ine o la innovación no termina con la
estructura del puente contiene un
conjunto de 12 sensores que analizan la
resistencia y permiten recopilar datos
sobre la atención temperatura y
vibración que se producen en la
estructura cuando la gente camina sobre
ella o con las distintas condiciones
climáticas hay sensores que documentarán
cuántas personas pasan por él
un momento dado eso nos ayudará a pensar
en cómo se comporta la gente en el
espacio público pero también en cómo se
desgastan nuestros puentes y canales
debido a esas personas
entonces nos da mucha información porque
se soluciona inside la impresión del
puente tomo alrededor de 6 meses y los
datos que sean recolectados por los
sensores servirán para crear una copia
digital lo que se conoce como un gemelo
digital que recreará las mismas
condiciones de la estructura y permitirá
implementar cambios para mejorar el
diseño y conocer cómo se comportará el
acero impreso en futuras construcciones
y finalizamos también hablando de otro
tipo de tecnología 3-d
esta vez nos referimos a una divertida
instalación que se encuentra en tokio y
muestra un gato gigante que duerme
maúlla y observa directamente a la gente
que se reúne en el lugar el felino de
tonos blancos negros y naranjas está en
el barrio de shinjuku una de las zonas
de compras más transitadas de la capital
japonesa y su proyección es posible
gracias a una pantalla curva led 4k de
alrededor de 155 metros cuadrados
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
recuerden que pueden repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]
i